bonjour et bienvenue je vais vous faire
embarquer à bord de lépine âge vous
allez pouvoir monter les uns après les
autres un petit pot de gel
hydroalcoolique juste le rendez vous est
donné à la capitainerie sous un soleil
radieux
axel et son bateau l'épinoche sont
prêtes à partir la balade découverte
peut débuter sur le canal d'orléans qui
fête cette année ses 100 ans
donc au relais ans a été longtemps l'un
des plus grand port fluvial sur la loi
et on a créé ce canal pour pouvoir faire
transiter les marchandises entre orléans
et paris
le marinier a décidé de rouvrir
progressivement en proposant tous les
jours pendant les vacances scolaires
une visite guidée découverte pour moi ce
qui me plaît plus est de faire découvrir
aux orléanais le patrimoine qu'ils ont g
j'ai envie d'essayer de transmettre aux
gens alors je sais pas tout un jeu juste
à marignier mais géant j'ai besoin que
les gens ils soient au courant de ce qui
s'est passé sur notre ville d'orléans
sur ce canal sur ce bief
c'est pas possible en été parce que ce
canal à des problèmes
d'approvisionnement en eau il n'y a pas
de travaux pour le moment qu'ils sont
prévus pour l'étanchéification donc
c'est vraiment une partie où on peut
naviguer que l'hiver une petite balade
très calme d'une demi-heure sur 4 km
l'occasion pour ces orléanais de
découvrir ce petit bout d'histoire en
famille connaissait pas tellement
orléans et suite aux bateaux à la petite
visite du canal ça nous fait vraiment un
petite histoire et c'est vraiment très
agréable et tout connaître un petit peu
l'histoire de cette ville lanceur les
ânesses mais c'est vraiment une
découverte pour moi c'est la preuve que
je suis un petit tour comme ça en bateau
avec vos conjoints et mon enfant
c'est vraiment très agréable avec les
beaux jours qui arrivent c'est un
plaisir à avec la crise ducobu 19 et le
couvre-feu à 18 heures la promenade est
d'autant plus appréciée là on en profite
on en profite on prend l'air
l'assainissement la balade coûte 7 euros
pour les adultes
le tarif a été revue à la baisse pour la
période les propriétaires des bateaux
mise sur la clientèle locale pour
remplacer les visiteurs étrangers
[Musique]